so it's that time of year again
everybody's talking about all these
crazy new habits they're gonna start
implementing in 2020 because in 2019 you
weren't living your real life in 2020
though that's gonna be the real you
that's gonna be the fully torqued [ __ ]
it's pretty much a meme at this point
that nobody follows through with their
New Year's resolutions at least 99.9% of
people don't you might make it two to
three days in two to three weeks in if
you're lucky but despite this fact it
doesn't stop millions and perhaps even
billions of people all around the world
from fantasizing about being a new and
reinvented version of themselves in 2020
I don't want to be a debbie downer or
anything like that
but this type of thinking generally
doesn't work and there's a very specific
reason for this one of the coolest
studies I've ever come across
showed that when human beings think of
their future self even themselves
tomorrow the same part of the brain
lights up that lights up when we think
about other people so we viewed this
future version of ourselves as someone
else entirely
if we have a certain amount of mental
resistance to going to the gym today we
assume that this other person this
future version of ourselves won't have
those same obstacles but when we get to
that point in time because it naturally
progresses forward we are still
encountered with that exact same
resistance and if you think about it
this is exactly what we do when we
fantasize about being this awesome
person in 2020 we imagine this different
person who is more motivated more
energetic better judgment and better
everything than we do right now to think
that we're going to be a different
person with more motivation tomorrow
than we are today is a it's kind of done
but to be fair though some people do
hype themselves up so much about New
Year's that when January first hits they
actually do have motivation to get out
of bed but the thing about New Year's is
like January 1st is super clean right
but that cleanness The effect of that
fresh slate starts to wear off extremely
quickly so if you actually want 2020 to
be the year where you finally figure
things out in either one or multiple
areas of your life then you have to take
it seriously you have to
have a game plan and one of the things
that's really helped me implement a new
behavior long term is to deconstruct the
behavior that I'm trying to implement
this strategy is especially important if
you're trying to implement something
significant like quitting smoking or
going to the gym every day let's use
smoking as an example but feel free to
replace smoking with anything that
you're thinking of so first what you
want to do is write down what are the
benefits that quitting smoking will
bring to my life then write down what
are the benefits that smoking currently
gives me and this one might sound weird
but there's a reason why you're smoking
not you but there's a reason why you're
doing a negative habit it does give you
something whether that's entertainment
or maybe it makes you feel good or maybe
it's an escape try to figure out why you
do what you don't want to do next write
down the negatives that will happen if
you don't quit smoking think about the
future what will a future look like
potentially if you don't quit smoking
and then finally write down what are the
negatives that you'll encounter by
quitting smoking use this question to
dive into the obstacles and struggles
you're likely to face along the way of
quitting smoking now let's break out of
the smoking example and try using
working out instead what are the
negatives that you'll encounter by
implementing working out everyday as a
habit well some of the negatives is that
it'll be super uncomfortable for you
early on another negative is that you're
gonna have to encounter and overcome the
mental resistance and the
rationalizations to not go to the gym
another obstacle that you might
encounter is that you might be more
tired all the time for the first couple
of weeks but anybody who's been to the
gym for long periods of time knows that
it will eventually make you more
energetic throughout the day but usually
any habit worth implementing is a little
bit of a struggle at first and you
really should take the time to dive into
what are some of those obstacles that
you need to overcome that way when
you're confronted with these obstacles
it's not some huge surprise by
meditating on these questions you can
really start to uncover the real reasons
why you want to quit reasons that are a
lot more powerful than it being January
1st or something like that
having this short journal on hand is
also extremely useful for figuring out
whether you're ready or willing to
actually implement this behavior or if
you should take on something a little
bit smaller but if you are ready then
this journal is also extremely useful
for looking back on when you're in the
thick of it maybe a couple days or weeks
or months into this new habit and you're
starting to get discouraged or fatigued
you can always look back and remember
why you started and what life was like
before hand and the benefits that you
are expecting to achieve and whether or
not you're achieving them or not I guess
what I'm trying to say with this video
is that if you're thinking of
implementing a new habit or lifestyle
into your life there's probably a really
good reason why and that reason is
unique to you and it's up to you to
bring that reason or that multitude of
reasons to the surface by writing it
down and let this writing serve as the
adequate ammunition that you need to
power your lifestyle long term
regardless of what day or month or year
it is but yeah that's pretty much it
this video is a little bit more of a
quick video because I'm I'm not at my
usual house I'm at my parents place but
before you go I would really recommend
you check out the best book on habits
I've read this year by far using today's
video sponsor audible a big thank you to
audible for sponsoring this video if
you're someone who generally struggles
to implement new habits into your life
it's hard to get new activity to stick
then I highly recommend atomic habits by
James clear inaudible this is by far one
of the best books I've read this year I
recommend the audible version
specifically because it's narrated by
the author and that always adds a lot
more personality and you can connect to
the book a lot easier for those of you
who don't know audible has the largest
selection of audiobooks on the entire
internet every single month you can
download one audio book of your choice
regardless of price absolutely free
along with two audible originals and if
you don't like the audiobook you can
easily exchange it at any time for a
different audiobook and if you cancel
your membership you still keep your
entire library of audiobooks so to get
started with your 30-day free trial
hit the link below visit audible.com
slash better ideas or text better ideas
to 5
five hundred one more time click the
link below visit audible.com slash
better ideas or text better ideas - 500
500 if you liked this video make sure to
hit like because when you hit like the
algorithm blesses me by shoving this
video in front of other people's faces
helping them out and helping me out in
the process it's a win-win hopefully
this video saves some people from
failing their New Year's resolutions
like two days in also if you're lurking
here consider subscribing and hitting
the bell icons so that you don't miss
future uploads and you can join that
notification gang and I can heart and
respond to your comments etc etc I just
want to say thank you for an awesome
year the growth on this channel was
crazy
I did not expect us to have almost
500,000 subscribers by now that is wild
to me and I really want to find new ways
to kind of up the production value and
share my ideas in a more effective way
so thank you so much for your continued
support I am really looking forward to
2020 and all the adventures it's gonna
bring it's gonna be the craziest year by
far I can guarantee you that but yeah
that's all for today thank you for
watching and we'll catch you in the next
decade